welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and marvel studios second day panel
at comic con 2022 made insane
announcements about everything for the
next two years all the way through the
end of phase six black panther what kind
of forever confirmed to end phase four
blade captain america new world order
thunderbolts daredevil warren again and
agatha coming to chaos thunderbolts in
phase five and then on to phase six
fantastic four avengers the kang dynasty
and avengers secret wars i'm gonna break
down everything we learned about the
future of mcu the titles the release
dates the casting news we know about
what might happen in all these stories
how they'll all connect and really how
this all finally gives some direction to
this multiverse saga because until now
it's really just seemed to be about
disconnected god logic and disney plus
miniseries is ending in wawas what
really is the multiverse saga and who is
coming back now my reaction to the black
panther wakana forever trailer is a
separate video already on the channel be
sure to check it out my in-depth frame
by frame breakdown of that trailer will
come out on monday it was a heavy one i
need some time with it thank you for
your patience for further reactions to
this moment by moment please check out
the break room episode of it jessica
clements zach huddleston john costa and
erica wu did such a good job reacting to
all that stuff i wish i could have been
in the room with them okay let's break
down all the release dates we know from
now till forever she-hulk is coming
august 17th 2022 black panther wakanda
forever november 11th 2022 ant-man the
wasp quantomania coming february 17th
2023 that will be the first title of
phase five secret invasion coming
sometime spring 2023 guardians of the
galaxy volume 3 coming may 6 2023 echo
is coming in the summer of 2023 loki's
season 2 is coming summer 2023 the
marvel's coming july 28 2023 blade has
release date finally november 3rd 2023
ironheart is coming fall 2023 the series
agatha coven of chaos formerly known as
zack of the house of harkness that is
coming winter 2023 slash winter 2024
daredevil born again an 18 episode
series coming spring 2024 captain
america new world order coming may 3rd
2024 the thunderbolts coming july 26
2024 that will end phase five on to
phase six fantastic four final answer
release date of november 8th 2024
avengers the kang dynasty coming may 5th
2025 avengers secret wars ending phase 6
in november 7 2025 now throughout phase
six there are a bunch of unfilled titles
two different series coming fall 2024
another series coming winter 2024
another title coming winter 2025 two
titles coming spring 2025 and two other
titles coming summer 2025. so of all
these let's start with black panther
wakanda forever this trailer was
heartbreaking and heart-pounding tanaka
is confirmed as neymar the submariner
technically marvel comics marvel's first
mutant ruler of the undersea kingdom of
atlantis this trailer shows us the
funeral process of t'challa we do not
know yet how t'tala will die in this
story the trailer does end with a new
character in a gold and black vibranium
suit presumably this is going to be
shuri but they did not show her face yet
dominique thorne is playing ribby
williams aka ironheart the most powerful
moment of the trailer was angela bassett
as queen raimonda in a heartbreaking
monologue about how she's lost her
family it looks like it's going to be
adapting the insane 2012 avengers vs
x-men storyline in which namor floods
wakanda with a tidal wave as part of
this conflict atlantis is weakened and
the character otuma another atlantean
who actually gets exiled from atlantis
long-time villain to name or ends up
becoming an ally with neymar and this
story is going to be the end of phase
four a phase that marvel execs have
recently described as a reaction to the
events of the infinity saga of endgame
so this story really makes sense as the
the last of the transitional stories
ryan coogler had an impossible task he
had no idea that chadwick boseman was
suffering from his illness and he wrote
out the sequel assuming that t'challa
was gonna be at the heart of the story
so he had to start from page one with a
completely new story knowing that
everyone is still grieving chadwick
boseman and there is no one universally
accepted way forward here so it looks
like they're going to be using the story
to say goodbye to chadwick boseman but
also to look forward to what comes next
and what comes next could be a lot of
different things especially now that
phase five and phase six are going to be
looking at multiversal resets of
everything but before we get to black
panther we're kind of forever we're
gonna have she-hulk coming august 17th
we gotta do a trailer for it and i'm
gonna react to it here here we go
[Music]
oh she already hooked out the hell man
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
[Music]
oh they've been the thunderclap you want
to go back to life as a lawyer i i
respect that
he doesn't mean that oh we're breaking
the fourth wall we're doing some fleabag
stuff here i'm enjoying this jennifer
wallace
namaste emile oblong serious conflict of
interest this man tried to kill my
cousin bruce yeah that's quite all right
oh
i'm very very small we haven't won that
power our universe is on the edge of a
precipice
oh lawyer
we do things by the book come on the
book of the
yeah yeah american
uh loss
book of shanty's the better book to go
by
let's do this
who are all these guys
you know that friend you had in high
school
who was way cooler than you were
attracted
got all the attention from everyone
oh
hello
oh she's like in a support group jealous
is that what i'm feeling
he tried to do the
matt murdock representing the defense i
don't know what that means okay so as we
expected charlie cox matt murdock is
going to appear and i like how he's got
a different version of the suit he's got
the baton that's more of the red on gold
it looks like very excited to see how
the show opens the doors to a lot of
different corners of the marvel world
because as a legal comedy right each
episode could be like kind of a case of
the week you have jamila jamil as
titania the longtime she-hulk villain we
never really got confirmation of this
but we saw the dodc throughout ms marvel
and it looked like we saw a headshot of
jamil jamil among their investigation
board dodc is obviously gonna be a big
part of this they're the ones running
this cube prison that's in the middle of
the desert actually this ends up
becoming the home base of the
thunderbolts in the future and now that
we've got the thunderbolts confirmed for
the future of the mcu this could be
setting up the thunderbolts a lot
especially since we're seeing tim roth
come back as emil blonsky abomination i
think he could be a big part of the
thunderbolts i love seeing wong in this
i really think really phase 4 should
have just been called the wong cinematic
universe because he has been kind of a
weird connective tissue to everything
all right i want to move on to the start
of phase five which is going to be
ant-man and the wasp quantomania coming
february 17 2023 catherine newton is now
going to be playing scott's daughter
cassie lang aka stature one of the young
avengers in the future peyton reed was
now on the panel explain how this is
going to be spending a lot more time in
the quantum realm and the quantum
problem is not what we think it is
according to read paul red says scott
lang is super proud of himself now for
saving the universe scott according to
him has been busy at work with a little
book and he says i don't know what i'm
allowed to say now we learned in ms
marvel that scott lang has a podcast
series called big me little me part of
this powered life aka this american life
but for superheroes and that's how the
world has learned a lot about what
happened in the events of infinity war
in game and now it looks like he's write
it all up in a book i just hope that he
dedicates a chapter to that rat that ran
across the quantum controls because
really that rat was the one thing that
changed everything there was some brief
footage shown of it of course john of
the majors is playing the villain kang
the conqueror we saw a variant of kang
the conqueror he who reigns in the
loki's season finale and now we're
seeing the full version of kang the
conqueror he had this awesome exchange
with scott where scott says i am an
avenger and kang says i'm a conqueror
and king follows up with you're an
avenger have i killed you before already
setting up that kang as a conqueror has
someone who has already lived countless
different lives and is the product of
several different timelines of kang of
course bill murray is confirmed in an
unknown role but he's gonna be playing
another life form someone who has a
history with janet van dyne and
recognizes her and the big headline here
modoc is confirmed to appear we don't
know the actor yet bill murray is not
gonna be playing modoc there is some
rumored speculation that corey stoll who
played yellowjacket darren cross in the
2015 ant-man might play a mutated
version of himself who has now become
modoc but as the start of phase five
quanah mania is going to be the story
that introduces us to kang the conqueror
as the ruler of a dynasty of kang's
across the timeline setting up all the
events of phase six all right on to the
next title secret innovation coming
spring 2023 kobe smulders came out on
stage to talk a bit about the show some
brief footage was shown of nick fury on
the run perhaps hunting scrolls don
cheadle is confirmed to be playing rudy
war machine in the story other than that
not a ton of updates about secret
invasion then guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 coming may 5th 2023 james gunn
came out on the stage with several in
the cast a very very emotional panel
james gunn said that vol 3 is gonna be
quote about the end that this is the end
of that story some stories have been end
doesn't mean everybody dies though we
got further confirmation that will
poulter is we playing adam warlock the
guy in the golden cocoon in the volume 2
post-credits scene and confirmation that
many of us have been speculating about
that chugi uchi who you might have seen
in the amazing series peacemaker that
james gunn directed is gonna be playing
herbert windham the high evolutionary
our man actually appeared in costume and
said i can't wait to dissect all of you
and see what i learn so herbert wyndham
high evolutionary a character of marvel
comics very connected to the mutants in
x-men and nathaniel essex mr sinister
the evolutionary would create these like
human animal cross breeds called the
anime men he actually had a castle on
mount wundagor it'd be awesome if this
somehow connected to multiverse of
madness but it sounds like this story is
gonna be very much about rocket james
gunn said that this movie's gonna be how
rocket is one of the saddest beings in
the universe there was some brief
footage shown all set to flaming lips do
you realize and we saw lots of stuff
including gamora hanging out with the
ravagers some shots of mantis doing a
weird little dance adam warlock is there
and there's a shot of a large hand
reaching into a cage to pet baby rocket
we're gonna see rocket's origin one of
the longest running mysteries from the
first guardians of the galaxy film why
he has those scars on his back why he's
so sensitive about his origin and how he
is not actually a raccoon he's a trash
panda but he's not a panda either he is
one of these creatures probably created
by herbert wyndham the high evolutionary
also we learned that maria bacalova is
going to be playing cosmo the space dog
who we saw in guardians vol 1 and in an
episode of what if she's gonna be doing
the voice okay next title echo coming
summer 2023 all we learned was really a
release date about it but maya lopez
coming back from hawkeye vincent
d'onofrio is going to appear in this
story as kingpin he did not die at the
end of pocket watch our hawkeye
breakdown to explain why that gunshot
didn't mean he died okay the marvels is
coming july 28 2023 we didn't have any
of the cast we didn't focus on it too
much but we know that kamala khan monica
rambo and carol danvers are all gonna be
part of the story we saw in the ms
marvel post credits scene that through
those bengals kamala khan and carol
danvers swapped places making it seem
like they are going to be the mega bands
i'm wondering monica rambo could be also
part of this maybe all three of them
share a link through the negative zone
and now that we know that kamala khan is
mutant i'm hoping that rogue could show
up in the story i'd love if they had
that comic story line where she drains
their powers okay we also saw that
loki's season 2 is coming summer 2023 it
is currently in production we don't know
too much about it yet big confirmation
we learned that blade is coming november
3rd 2023 mahershala ali is playing blade
i'm assuming he's going to connect with
dane whitman based off of the
post-credits scene of eternals in a plot
involving the ebony blade there are some
rumors that anything star from the boys
is being approached to play dracula
though those rumors have not been
confirmed yet iron hearts rio williams
joining the mcu in black panther wakanda
forever but she's gonna get her own mini
series in fall 2023 and then in winter
2023 2024 we got agatha the heartless
solo series which is now titled agatha
coven of chaos formerly titled ag of the
house of harkness coven of chaos why did
they change the name well chaos probably
a reference to chaos magic which is the
kind of power that wanda maximoff uses
but this idea of a coven makes us wonder
who else is in the coven let's claim to
hope that elizabeth olsen will return in
the series i believe that elizabeth
olson is trapped in hell major
confirmation here daredevil born again a
series lasting 18 episodes coming spring
2024 starring charlie cox's matt murdock
daredevil and vincent d'onofrio as
wilson fist kingpin this is the largest
episode release order we have gotten yet
in the mcu disney plus episode series 18
episodes
what is this a cbs show that her
grandparents watch i love this not only
gonna get to spend more time with these
characters the writers are gonna get
more work now charlie cox was already
introduced in spider-man no way home
he's gonna appear in shield prosecuting
some cases alongside jennifer walters
now portigan of course the name of one
of the most famous daredevil runs by
frank miller that was actually i think
one of the first marvel comics story
lines i read because i started reading
dc comics i knew frank miller from dc
comics i'm like oh that guy did
daredevil too cool born again just
incredible i'm so excited for this
series okay next the fourth captain
america film captain america new world
order coming may 3rd 2024 anthony mackie
is now captain america in the mcu after
the falcon the winner soldier malcolm
spellman is gonna be writing the
screenplay he's the guy behind the
falcon the winter soldier now new world
order what does that mean this is a 20th
century political term that really
started with people like woodrow wilson
and winston churchill when the league of
nations was being formed in the
aftermath of world war one to talk about
how geopolitics has really shifted now
the term new world order is really
associated with conspiracy theories and
that's what i hope this title digs into
what has been great about the captain
america films in the mcu is that they do
not shy away from politics obviously the
first one was more of a throwback film
exploring world war ii but also the dark
side of war propaganda captain america
the winter soldier my favorite mcu film
dug into things like government
surveillance and uses of drones captain
america civil war explored the political
ramifications of the events of age of
ultron and how every time you're kicking
ass to save the world there's always a
body count so now this fourth cap film
to explore conspiracy theories i mean
this following multiverse of madness
actually using the term illuminati
fascinating and it shows that the mcu is
not afraid to explore how these topics
are warping our political lives and then
phase five will end with thunderbolts
coming july 26 2024 i think it's
fascinating that this is coming right
after new world order because the
thunderbolts is the dark avengers
everything that we've seen val been
doing julie louis dreyfus character
assembling another team including elena
belova john walker we assume abomination
i assume the thunderbolts is going to be
her version of avengers that the
american public rallies behind but
actually they're a bunch of [ __ ] and
then on to phase six starting with the
fantastic four november 8 2024. all we
know is a release date for this movie
we're probably going to meet some of the
cast at d23 i would imagine and the fact
that we're getting fantastic four in the
year 2024 confirms my theory that we're
going to see doom appear in some
upcoming post-credits scene within the
next year now we did meet john krasinski
as reed richards in the 838 universe of
the multiverse of madness and the
producers of that movie confirmed that
his portal was based on doom's time
platform so the question is what
universe are we going to meet the
fantastic four in are we going to meet
the fantastic four in marvel 616. are we
going to meet several different versions
of the fantastic four how the fantastic
four been there the whole time dr
strange had that line of didn't you guys
chart in the 60s uh which is obviously
just a joke about like the beatles and
other fab four music groups and that
stephen strange has that kind of like
music knowledge but i would love this
movie establish that in the 60s there
was a fantastic four in the 616 mcu that
was peyton reed's pitch for a fantastic
four movie back in the day i think as
the first movie of phase six it's gonna
be a very important for this movie to
set up the rules for the multiverse to
actually give us some terms they can
hint at it and the upcoming titles in
phase five but this is the movie that's
really gonna have to set the rules of
the road reid's whole incursion speech
multiverse madness was based on john
hickman's storyline leading up to secret
wars in the comics i need to see some
diagrams feige give me a textbook okay
on to avengers the kang dynasty coming
may 5th 2025. so we met the variant of
kang and the end of loki i assume we're
going to be exploring more of the kang
variants in loki's season 2 and of
course we're going to be kang the
conqueror and ant-man the was quantum
mania and what's so fascinating about
kang is that these versions of kang can
all die they can be defeated but kang is
like a whack-a-mole there are infinite
numbers of kang who can keep reappearing
and pulling the rug out from underneath
you he's impossible to kill you gotta
find kang prime you gotta go back to the
origin point of the kangs the origin
point by the way nathaniel richards in
31st century an origin that also gives
us iron lad for the young avengers my
hope for this story the kang dynasty is
that we just let jonathan majors take
over the story and play several
different versions of himself kang vs
kang and we do something that the second
act of end game did that i kind of
wanted all of endgame to be which is to
revisit all the events in the 616 mcu
timeline to learn why the sacred
timeline was so sacred and how it was
really crafted by a version of kang or
versions of kang every major nexus
moment every branch pruned was done so
by kang for a specific reason in general
i'm not crazy when fictional franchises
say this is one character who behind it
all other than when they said it was
agatha all along kang is the ultimate
bad guy you can do that with though
because that is what the marvel comics
did so many characters were found to
have been influenced by kang at some
point and this will set the stage for
avengers secret wars the end phase six
coming november 7th 2025. now the russo
brothers have been asked many times
whether they are going to be directing
this story they keep playing coy about
it i think they're really the directors
for the job now there are two eras of
secret wars in the marvel comics there
was one of the 80s with the beyonder and
there was one in 2015 where it was
doctor doom behind it all i think
they're gonna be doing the latter the
2015 storyline just because of
everything reid said in multiverse of
madness he was using some of the same
dialogue from the storylines that led
into that secret wars what will be the
universe's colliding in secret wars
obviously 616 but with who else 838 1610
i don't know if you can have a secret
wars without a miles morales without a
robert downey jr tony stark without the
x-men without the fantastic four this is
the storyline where you get everyone to
come back robert downey jr chris evans
scarlett johansson we didn't hear
anything about the x-men in this panel i
think they're gonna be coming in d23 and
now we had plenty of time to get the
x-men into the mcu because if you look
at that phase six lineup there are
several open slots on that calendar that
they have not revealed yet i think
they're gonna be revealed at d23 and i
think we're gonna see the x-men in phase
five and phase six that is everything we
learned at this panel but again d23
coming we didn't learn anything about
armor wars or wonder man werewolf by
night we didn't hear anything about a
wanda maximoff solo title i'm still
holding on to hope that we will again my
breakdown of the black panther workout
forever trailer is coming monday on the
channel and there's so much to talk
about i'm so pumped to now finally know
where the mcu is going follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
new rockstar subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you